monsieur l'allemand nous sommes ici pour
comprendre la nature et les auteurs des
violences lors des manifestations
or votre gestion de l'ordre dans les
manifestations lorsque vous étiez préfet
de police a été largement remise en
cause décrié par de nombreux
observateurs
pour des choses clairement vous avez été
accusé d'avoir provoqué des violences
pendant les manifestations
notamment par l'intermédiaire des braves
m bravèmes on la prend aujourd'hui
auquel appartenu le policier qui a tué
Naël Abou portant un Nanterre mais
revenons
à l'objet de cette commission et à votre
politique du maintien de l'ordre qui a
notamment été documentée par un article
de Mediapart une enquête de mars 2020 en
quête qui révèle que des hauts
responsables de la gendarmerie jugez vos
pratiques illégales
illégales notamment parce que vous
incitiez vos troupes à impacté je cite
c'est le terme les manifestants c'est à
dire en haut à rentrer dans le tas
qu'est-ce que vous répondez
assez critique et mise par des membres
des forces de l'ordre pas par des
factieux pas par des gauchistes par des
membres des forces de l'ordre placées
sous vos ordres qui vous accusent très
clairement d'avoir été lorsque vous
étiez préfet de police à l'origine de
nombreuses violences constatées dans des
manifestations dont vous aviez la
responsabilité du bon déroulement
monsieur le député je suis navré mais je
ne dis pas Médiapart pour moi ça n'est
pas le Journal officiel et ça n'est pas
la Bible donc je ne sais pas ce qui s'y
raconte est-ce que j'ai eu des reproches
d'un certain nombre de fonctionnaires
aux militaires classés sous mon autorité
sur les dispositifs de manifestations
qui étaient mis en place si je comprends
bien c'est votre question voire même des
reproches de laurier Archie organique en
la matière jamais jamais jamais jamais
et Dieu sait si pourtant je réunissais
l'ensemble des effectifs avant par
exemple manifestation
ça se passe de la façon suivante sur la
préfecture de police c'est que l'avant
veille la veille lorsque les dispositifs
sont compliqués l'ensemble des
commandants de compagnie ou d'unités
sont réunis s'agissant des gendarmes
puisque chaque structure c'est reste
gendarmes à un dispositif de
transmission des des informations dans
la gendarmerie ça s'appelle le Gaumont
qui est placé auprès dans la salle de
commandement c'est-à-dire le chef du
dispositif gendarmerie si vous voulez le
chef des dispositif CRS qui sont dans la
salle de commandement qui suivent les
dispositifs jamais jamais aucun d'entre
eux ne m'a parlé de la moindre chose
voilà donc je n'ai jamais eu la moindre
reproche et de leur part de leur
hiérarchie nationale non plus jamais de
ailleurs du côté du ministre donc
franchement je ne vois absolument pas ce
dont il s'agit